PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
You've been talking
about computing limits
of some indeterminate forms.
In particular, you
used l'Hopital's rule
to help you out with some
limits in the form 0 over 0
or infinity over infinity.
So these are the two
indeterminate ratios.
And you also--
so, OK so when you
have a limit that is in the
form of an indeterminate ratio,
you've seen that
one tool that you
can use to help compute the
limit is l'Hopital's rule.
There are other indeterminate
forms for limits as well.
So you actually saw,
in lecture, another one
of these, which was you saw a
limit of the form 0 to the 0.
So that was the limit
you saw, was the limit
as x goes to 0 from the
right of x to the x.
So that was going to 0 over 0.
And the two competing forces are
that as the base of the limit
goes to 0, that wants to make
the whole thing get closer
to 0.
And when the exponent
is going to 0,
that makes the whole thing
want to get closer to 1.
So you have those
two competing forces.
That's why it is an
indeterminate form.
When you were
solving this limit,
you-- first thing you did was
you wrote it as an exponential
in base e.
So you wrote x to the
x as e to the x*ln x.
So x*ln x is also an
indeterminate form as x goes
to 0.
It's an indeterminate form
of the form 0 times infinity.
Here I'm writing
infinity to mean
either positive infinity
or negative infinity.
So in this case, this
is an indeterminate form
because when you have
one factor going to 0,
that makes the whole product
want to get closer to 0.
Whereas when you have one
factor going to infinity,
either positive or negative,
that makes the whole product
want to get big.
So that's why it
becomes indeterminate.
And you were able to evaluate
the limit x*ln x, in that case,
by rewriting it as a quotient.
There are a few other
indeterminate forms
that I'd like to mention.
So in particular, there are
three other indeterminate forms
different from these.
And then I'll give you
an example of one of them
to solve a problem.
so the three other
indeterminate forms,
there are two more that are sort
of an exponential indeterminate
form, and there's
one sort of outlier.
So one of the other
indeterminate forms
is infinity to the 0.
So when you have an
exponential expression where
the base is getting
very, very large,
and the exponent is going to
0, well the base getting large
makes the whole
fraction want to be
sorry the whole expression
want to be large,
whereas the exponent going to 0
makes the whole expression want
to get closer to 1.
And so those two
forces are in tension,
and you can end up
with limits that
equal any value when you
have a limit like this,
infinity to the 0.
Another similar one
is 1 to the infinity.
And this is the one I'll give
you an exercise on in a minute.
So when you have a
limit of the form 1
to the infinity, so something to
the something where the base is
going to 1 and the exponent
is going to infinity,
the base going to 1 makes this
whole thing want to go to 1.
The exponent to infinity
makes this whole thing
want to either blow up if
it's a little bigger than 1,
or get really small if it's
a little smaller than 1.
So you have, again,
a tension there,
and the result is indeterminate.
The one sort of unusual
one that you have is also--
which I'm not going to
talk much more about--
is infinity minus infinity.
So when you have two
very large things,
so here I mean either
positive infinity
minus positive infinity,
or negative infinity
minus negative infinity.
When you have two things that
are both getting very large,
their difference could
also be getting very large,
or it could be
getting very small,
or could be doing
anything in between.
So that's also an
indeterminate form.
So these are the seven
indeterminate forms.
When you have a
quotient, you can always
apply l'Hopital's rule.
When you have a
product, you can always
rewrite it as a
quotient, by writing
for example, x squared
plus 1 times-- well,
let's see-- e to the minus x.
That's a product.
And you could always
rewrite it as a quotient,
for example, e to the minus x
over 1 over x squared plus 1.
There might even
be a smarter way
to rewrite this
product as a quotient.
But, OK.
And so when you have an
exponential, as in this case,
you can use this
rewriting in base e trick
to turn it into a product,
which you can then
turn into a quotient.
For the difference case, the
reason I say it's unusual,
is just that there's not
a good, general method
for working with these.
There are a lot
of special cases.
And you sort of have
to or what I mean
is you have to analyze them
on a case by case basis.
There are different sort of
techniques that will work.
So let me give you
an example of one
of these 1 to the
infinity kinds.
So why don't we come over here.
So compute the
limit as x goes to 0
from the right of 1 plus
3x to the 10 divided by x.
So we see as x is going to
0, this base is going to 1.
And so that makes this
whole expression want
to be close to 1, whereas this
exponent is going to infinity,
since this is just a
little bit bigger than 1,
that makes the whole
expression want to be big
when the exponent is big.
So you have a tension here
between the base going to 1
and the exponent
going to infinity.
So the question is, try and
actually compute this limit.
So why don't you pause the
video, take a couple of minutes
to work on this
question, come back,
and we can work on it together.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you had some luck
working on this problem.
As we said, this is a limit of
an indeterminate form of the 1
to infinity type.
As one of the three exponential
types of indeterminate forms,
a really promising first
step almost every time
is to rewrite this as a
exponential expression
with the base e.
So we just do-- first we just
do an algebraic manipulation
on the thing we're taking
the limit of, and then often,
very often, that simplifies
it into something that we can
actually compute the limit of.
So in particular, we
have that 1 plus 3x,
if we want to write this
in exponential form,
this is equal to e to
the ln of 1 plus 3x.
This is true of any
positive number.
Any positive number is e
to the ln of it, because e
and log are inverse functions.
So OK, so we write it like this.
And so that means that 1
plus 3x to the 10 over x
is equal to e to the ln of
1 plus 3x to the 10 over x.
And now you can use
your exponent rules.
So this is equal to e to the ln
of 1 plus 3x times 10 over x.
So our original expression
is equal to this down here.
So the limit of our
original expression
is equal to the
limit of this one.
The other thing to notice is
that because exponentiation
is a nice, continuous
function, in order
to compute this limit, or
the limit of this expression,
it suffices-- just
with base a constant,
e-- it suffices to compute
the limit of the exponent.
All right, so let's do that.
Let's compute the
limit of the exponent.
So we have the limit,
so it has to be
x going to the same
place, which in this case
is to 0 from the right, of ln
of 1 plus 3x times 10 over x.
Well, this is a product.
It came to us as a product.
But there's an obvious way to
rewrite this as a quotient.
I should say it's an
indeterminate product.
As x goes to 0, this goes
to ln of 1, which is 0.
Whereas this goes to infinity,
positive infinity since we're
coming from the right.
So this is a 0 times
positive infinity form.
So it is an indeterminate
limit or sorry
an indeterminate product.
And, right, and
there's an obvious way
to rewrite this as an
indeterminate quotient,
which is to rewrite
it as the limit
as x goes 0 plus of
10 ln of 1 plus 3x
divided by x, as x goes 0.
So now, this is a limit where
it's an infinity-- sorry--
a 0 over 0 form.
So OK, so good.
So now we can apply
l'Hopital's rule.
So by l'Hopital's rule,
this is equal to the limit
as x goes to 0 on
the right of-- well,
we apply l'Hopital's rule
on the top, we get 10 over 1
plus 3x, by the
chain rule, times 3.
And on the bottom,
we just get one.
So now, OK, so this
is true provided
this second limit exists.
And the second limit is
no longer indeterminate.
It's easy to see what it is.
You just plug in
x equals 0, and we
get that this is equal to 30.
OK so this limit is equal to
30, but this isn't the limit
that we started out
wanting to compute.
The limit we started
out wanting to compute
is e to the ln of 1
plus 3x times 10 over x.
So it's e to the this.
So our original limit as x
goes to 0 from the right of 1
plus 3x to the 10
over x is equal to e
to the thirtieth power,
which is pretty huge.
OK, so that's how we--
right-- and OK, so that's
the answer to our question.
So we took our
original limit, it
was this indeterminate
exponential form.
So what we do to it
is, when you have
an indeterminate
exponential form,
you do this rewriting as an
exponential in the base of e
trick, and then you pass
the limit into the exponent.
Because e is now
a nice constant,
life is simple-- life is
simpler I should say-- you pass
the limit into
the constant, then
you have an indeterminate ratio,
indeterminate product, which
you rewrite as an
indeterminate ratio
on which you can then
apply l'Hopital's rule.
Or possibly, you know, you
rewrite it as a product.
Then it's easy to see
what the value is.
So, all right, so
that's how we deal
with limits of indeterminate
exponential forms.
And I'll end there.